t l'épidémiologiste antoine flahault
antoine flahault bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous vous êtes médecin grand
spécialiste des épidémies
alors le premier ministre a surpris tout
le monde hier avec ses annonces plus de
masques à l'extérieur fin du couvre-feu
avec dix jours d'avancé
une décision raisonnable selon vous oui
la situation en france mais c'est vrai
aussi dans presque toute l'europe
peut-être un par le royaume uni et le
portugal
la situation s'améliore très très
rapidement le taux de reproduction est
très inférieure à 1 il était autour de
0,6 hier en france donc on est vraiment
dans une situation où il ya moins de
2000 cas par jour peut-être dans une
semaine moins de 1000 cas par jour
nouvelles contaminations par jour sur le
territoire national c'est donc tout à
fait judicieux aujourd'hui de lever ces
mesures notamment le masque à
l'extérieur n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
la seule chose peut-être qu'ils auraient
pu être précisée à mon avis est qu'il
faut recommander le port du masque à
l'extérieur lorsqu'il ya des pics de
pollution et skinn as on peut dire rien
à voir et en fait si les pics de
pollution sont associés à des pics de co
vide
donc il est toujours bien s'il ya une
très forte pollution aux particules
fines de continuer à porter le masque
mais c'est à mon avis la seule
circonstance on devrait le mettre
alors depuis déjà quelques jours avec la
hausse des températures on observe mans
de vigilance
ne craignez-vous pas un relâchement
total de la part des français
non je pense que les français ont
beaucoup contribué à limiter l'extension
de l'épidémie et c'était leur rôle quand
les autorités sanitaires ne pouvait pas
le faire parce qu'il y avait trente
mille cas par jour et que l'on pouvait
pas demander aux autorités sanitaires de
tester tracé isoler efficacement à
partir du moment où il ya moins de 1000
ou 2000 cas par jour
les autorités sanitaires sont en devoir
je crois 2
retracer et de démanteler toutes les
chaînes de contamination sur le
territoire et ça a été extrêmement bien
fait dans les landes par exemple puisque
aujourd'hui la nouvelle aquitaine n'est
pas une région qui est particulièrement
affectée par une décontamination
communautaire je pense que toutes les
nouvelles chaînes de contaminations vont
être identifiées
tous les virus vont pouvoir être
séquencés puisque c'est la capacité de
séquençage française 1000 à 2000
séquençage par jour et donc ce sera
exhaustif on doit pouvoir avoir une
veille sanitaire qui reprend
complètement la main qui sécurise les
frontières et qui de ce fait laisse aux
français la possibilité de se relâcher
beaucoup plus alors vous demandiez début
juin en faire attention justement à ne
pas des confiné trop vite avec le risque
d'un plateau à cette crainte est elle
toujours existantes aujourd'hui je
trouve que le gouvernement français a
des consignes et très prudemment
vous savez le 19 mai on a ouvert les
terrasses et on a bien vu d'ailleurs que
le milieu extérieur n'est pas un milieu
à risques de propagation puisque les
gens étaient très agglutinés les uns
avec les autres
c'était très bon décès terrasse et il
n'y avait aucune contamination et les
gens n'avaient pas de masque par
définition ils étaient des bars ou des
restaurants en train de consommer donc
on voit bien que ça n'a pas été associée
à une recrudescence de l'épidémie
c'était très prudentielles et je pense
que c'était tout à fait bien de faire
cela ainsi le 9 juin la l'ouverture des
bars et des restaurants a été
accompagnée d'une amie une situation
épidémiologique favorable on était déjà
au dessous de 5000 cas par jour
et même si ces mesures gouvernementales
à l'époque n'était pas je dirais
conditionnée aux indicateurs sanitaires
peut-être par chance toujours est il que
les indicateurs sanitaires eux étaient
en accord avec ces cette levée des
restrictions
et puis maintenant je crois qu'en effet
quand on arrive à à moins de 2000 cas
par jour
cette tour est licite de
lever les quelques dernières mesures qui
reste à mon avis dans les transports en
commun dans les lieux clos pendant tout
l'été ce sera bien de continuer à porter
un masque
l'épidémie n'est pas terminée elle est
en déclin
beaucoup aussi craignent d'une nouvelle
vague à la rentrée quand on regarde
aussi ce qui se passe chez nos voisins
anglais avec la propagation du variant
delta il ya de quoi s'inquiéter puisque
invariants delta qui est présent
également en france oui je partage votre
inquiétude je pense que en effet la
situation au royaume uni mais aussi au
portugal aussi en russie d'ailleurs donc
dans plusieurs pays de la zone europe du
continent européen
sont des zones préoccupante les
britanniques ont ouvert leurs frontières
avec l'inde qui est une où il ya une
diaspora importante au royaume uni qui
est une ancienne colonie et où les
relations sont très étroites mais ils
l'ont fait sans prudence et aujourd'hui
ils en payent les conséquences parce
qu'il avait une épidémiologie très
proche de celle que nous vivons en ce
moment en europe continentale c'est à
dire une décrue très prononcé et
malheureusement ça repart et ils ont du
mal à verrouiller et à reprendre
complètement le contrôle
on peut penser que cependant leur
réaction maintenant assez précoce le
retard du d'un mois des mesures finales
de déconfinement vont leur permettre de
reprendre la main et vont leur permettre
d'éviter qu'il y ait cette vague nous en
europe continentale et en france en
particulier
je dirais que ça va dépendre de la
qualité de la prise en charge par les
autorités sanitaires de ces chaînes de
contamination si les autorités se
comporte comme elles se sont comportés
dans les landes
à chaque fois qu'un nouveau foyer est en
train d'émerger
on pourra éviter une quatrième vague à
l'automne en plus avec la vaccination
qui progresse si jamais les autorités
sanitaires faiblissent et ne n'applique
pas bien ces mesures alors on est
toujours à risque en effet de
débordements et de l'arrivée de cette
nouvelle vague
dernière question concernant justement
la vaccination c'est que le bon
demont souhaite atteindre les 35
millions de vaccinés fin août
les personnes qui souhaitaient le faire
se sont fait vacciner les autres
faudra-t-il les obliger alors la notion
d'une obligation vaccinale c'est une
notion politique ce n'est pas une notion
scientifique moi je suis un
épidémiologiste ce que je préfère c'est
que le tout le monde soit vacciné le
plus possible on y arrive très bien avec
la vaccination contre la rougeole il ya
plus de 95% des français vaccinés la
poliomyélite le tétanos aussi donc il
faut considérer que le grenat virus est
une plaie dans nos sociétés qui légitime
totalement une vaccination très simple
et très massives il faut en tout cas que
plus de 85 % de la population soit
vaccinée
je ne sais pas si ça doit passer par des
obligations personnellement dans le je
suis médecin dans le milieu de santé le
milieu des soignants je trouve que ce
serait normal que la vaccination soit
obligatoire dans le reste de la
population
c'est en est tout à fait capable de
vacciner sans la rendre obligatoire si
ça n'est pas le cas peut-être que dans
certains endroits et où dans certains
segments de la population
ça pourrait être une obligation merci
beaucoup en tout cas antoine flahault
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
spécialiste des épidémies